i uh want to bring in rick stroud he
covers the buccaneers in the nfl for the
tampa bay times man life is
good there in tampa you got it all rick
you got the lightning
got the rays the buccaneers are back
anything any worries here none
it's title town tampa bay dan it really
is
unfortunately it's a fandemic and that
nobody can go to the games right i mean
they had like 15 000 at raymond james
but
nah man this is as good as it's ever
ever been
explain that first quarter though when
the buccaneers are down
ten nothing rogers doing what rogers
does
everything's looking good and then what
happened
and then uh todd bowles got them on the
sideline and said i know you respect
aaron rodgers but you guys are
respecting him a little bit too much go
out here and start making plays and
that's what jamel dean did
and i'm telling you it was an avalanche
after that i mean once he made that
interception
they just fed off of it i think after
the 10 to nothing league they had like
57
total yards the rest of the game i mean
it was incredible and
of course you know when you hit aaron
rodgers or any of those older
quarterbacks they don't like that
dan didn't you expect to see like jake
from state farm show up at some point
right when things are going that bad
for rogers i i still when i'm watching
i i the defense should stand out more
than it does
because that's an elite defense that's a
top five defense
this is all about tom brady and he sucks
up all the headlines but
that was what was interesting is i was
reminded how good the buccaneers defense
can be
why is that that it's are we missing it
i mean has it been there but we're just
noticing tom brady good or bad
i think it's been there since about the
last half of last year i mean they led
the nfl in uh turnovers and and they
were one of the top defenses once that
secondary grew up those young guys and
todd bowles we know
is one of the best you know defensive
minds in the game between his disguises
and his blitzes he comes from all over
those guys have really bought in and um
you know i do think that tom brady
has sucked all the oxygen you know out
of this franchise for a reason i mean
he's here to try to raise the level of
accountability and all that but you know
really is it much different i know tom's
skill set is still better than peyton
manning but what did peyton manning do
when he went to denver right
he was sort of a of a passenger on the
way to with a great defense to the super
bowl so
um you know when you talk to devon white
you talk to lavonte david and those guys
they don't take a back seat to the
offense they know they get all the
headlines and all the money and all that
stuff but they really feel like they're
the
they're the engine that's going to drive
this thing but do you think brady
would accept is he a game manager
uh i don't know i'm having trouble
trying to read tom because there are
games like yesterday
i think he answered about four zoom
questions and he didn't seem
he didn't seem all that hyped up about
about how he played you know he had 160
yard passing
uh they didn't have a very good start to
the game he's been really good in the
red zone but they've had guys in and out
of the lineup so i don't think he's
he's thrilled with what he's doing yet
um but i know he's glad they're winning
i mean he has said you gotta find ways
to win these games and i think yesterday
i mean they served notice
they can beat one of the top teams in in
the nfc so
let's see if they can keep that going
what do you think is going to be the big
hiccup
with this team or the thing to keep an
eye on
i think it's just that you know they got
to find a way to get healthy and stay
there they're not real deep i mean
that's the thing you know you look at
this defense and you're playing with a
33 year old jason pierre-paul
you're playing with a a a 31 year old
jay spirit ball 33 year old in domicon
su
there's not much behind those guys
obviously the linebackers are great
the secondary is young but it's like
most teams you don't have a lot of depth
especially these days you can't bring
players in
so they're gonna have to be lucky and i
think that's probably what got them on
offense in chicago on a short week with
a bunch of guys that were hurt you can't
have that
even at receivers they're not that deep
but if i'm going to say boy the
buccaneers are a super bowl contender
don't i have to say that the chicago
bears are a super bowl contender because
they beat the tampa bay buccaneers who
are a super bowl contender
yeah if you're gonna do the daisy chain
thing yeah for sure but i mean i don't
know that uh
i really believe the bucks felt like
they were they gave that game away look
they had the lead with
what under three minutes to go couldn't
get a first down
then you know tom somehow forgets what
down it is with the four fingers i mean
i still don't know what that's all about
so i i think they look at that you know
there's gonna be games where
if you're not ready to play you have
over 100 yards of penalties
you're going to lose it doesn't matter
who you're playing and i don't know why
the bears maybe don't have the respect
they probably deserve but they they
really felt they gave that game away
have you driven by tom's new house that
he bought in tampa
you know there's some controversy about
that i don't think he bought that
we called the realtor they go it's not
tom brady's house it's not his
corporation's house
it's too small dan it's only 8 000
square feet i mean i don't
he's living in a 30 000 square foot
house right now i think that would be
downsizing for tom brady i don't know
that he actually bought that one
did jeter is jeter kicking him out yeah
yeah he's selling it how much is that
thing is that a 30 million dollar home
uh yeah i think so i think it's close to
yeah i think it's close to 30 million 28
30 million dollars so
i think the rent on that is about 250
000 or so you can scrape that up then
why don't we care where gronk lives in
tampa
i don't know um that's a great question
you know he had a house down here and he
sold it now he's back his mom's just
down the road so
bronx kind of a mama's boy that way but
uh i guarantee
he's got a hot tub oh yeah probably
several those probably one inside and
outside
good to visit with you rick good to see
you smiling there
yeah well you know maybe we can have
nice things dad
time to las vegas thank you rick that's
uh rick stroud covers the buccaneers in
the nfl for the tampa bay times